um what
i think we we're all looking forward to
and uh with without further ado
i'll try and start this particular
banter blitz session
with a five minute game and
let's try and return to
my old love the the rat
and see if
people have started taking it
seriously to prepare for it
um bishop d3
yeah i talked about this before vision
d3 is not
it's not a bad move at all let me try c5
this is the idea of bishop d32
oh c3 actually that could be quite
clever
um yeah let me take a d4
the idea of vision d3 there is to
develop without putting the knights on
on uh c3 to play c3
yourself at a later stage or even even
c4
uh so here i've decided to play
um to play without um
g7 for the moment and i think in the
in the spirit of uh of the rat
i have to uh uh
i have to play this way
uh and yeah normally you would go
knight h5 here bishop g4
you come i'm thinking h3 then maybe
knight to g7 try and exchange
the bishops to bishop f5
but i'm a little bit worried that it's a
bit time consuming so i'm gonna
try and put the knights in a more active
square instead
um yeah
castles i'm not thrilled about this
because
eventually i think i'll have to trade
everything
on on c3 and then d3 and then
my opponent's gonna have a very very
good good control over
the center obviously the c3 would be
a bit of a target for me in the future
but i do think um
the fact that the whole white structure
is so so
stable and my king will have some
worries
here in finding a safe home i think
this means that well it has to be
to be somewhat better i think i'll go
age six now
just to prevent bishop g5 and
possibly intending bishop e7 and then
um then start
start working the king with the
the uh um f8 to g7
don't love it though um
also whenever i go bishop here
besides the fact that the bishop is not
so well placed there
bishop a3 is also is also a bit of an
issue
um so
all in all i've got some some
difficulties here
but i do have some
positional prompts in the long run um
in terms of uh yeah in terms of
a better construction on the on the on
the queen side
but i think for the moment that's a
bit of a it's a bit of a pipe dream
and i think white is considerably better
but um all to play for of course
[Music]
h4 is very logical
attending both h5 at some point
and also and also possibly
um knight h2 to g4 so i'll try to
prevent the first of those plans
if h5 for better or worse i think i just
have to take it
still castle queen side at some moment
so it's not like my
my king is is just stuck
to forever being in the center here
knight a5 um at the very least
asking asking some questions
or rather one question which is to i'm
asking
him to defend the a4 pawn and queen c6
now possibly intending rook c8 and then
king d7
yeah with the bishop to d2
there's not so much point in in going um
and going rook c8 because that's the
pawn is already protected so i'll just
go knight c4
now that also knight d2 is no longer an
option trying to trade those
knights um and now i'm threatening to go
a6 and wind up on a4
and since my opponent did not prevent
that that is exactly what i'm gonna do
next i'll i'll take i'll play queen c6
back
and then i'll go b5 possibly
later bring the king to d7
and without
without that
[Music]
pawn on uh on a4 i think i have a very
solid construction over there
uh yeah so he just put me in check but i
think i'll just take it
i'll go queen c6 as planned
don't see any any great threats here
possibly possibly rookie six
i'll take it probably fe six because
queen e6 rookie one doesn't look too
clear um i'll probably take it yeah
v6 and then queen g6 i'll go king
d8 and hope for the best
not too clear though he should try it
because otherwise he could be in a lot
of trouble
yeah f4 is no good because it
effectively just killed bishop and he'll
probably have to go f5 later on
to to activate to activate
um the bishop which is in a bit of a
sorry state at the moment
i think this could be very clearly one
of those cases of
good night versus bad bishop i'll go b5
always aesthetical to put all the pawns
in the same
color complex
and then i'll possibly start rerouting
the
knight maybe two d6 and then e4 or
trying gobble ups and pawns
yeah i should be should be playing
sailing now
94 and um
once f6 falls then i really don't have a
lot to worry about
g4 this is desperation of course
and uh i lost some time
okay uh i don't know if it was
a beautiful game um but
certainly an interesting interesting
strategic fight there
fortunately for me i managed to to get
the upper hand there
eventually